this weekend marks the start of summer
but some of our favorite warm weather
activities can be damaging to our skin
celebrity dermatologist dr. Anna
gwanghae is here to help she has what
you need to know before taking that
first dip in the pool how does that
affect your skin to be swimming in the
chlorine is it drying and what can we do
yes the chlorine reaches the moisture
out of your skin so after you're done
swimming the best thing to do is to
rinse off and then apply a good
moisturizer not just for your body on
your face in addition to wearing
sunscreen
dr. gwanghae recommends regular
exfoliation to ditch that dead skin use
a cotton pad and use your usual cleanser
and apply a circular motion that helps
exfoliate your skin and then make sure
you're using products that contain
active ingredients that really work so
we teamed up with dr. Guan che and ROC
skincare to help keep your skin hydrated
not just in the summer but all year
round I love rock retinol correction max
hydration cream it contains 2 of my
favorite ingredients it has retinol
which helps with wrinkles and it also
has hyaluronic acid which we know is a
great moisturizer it delivers 24-hour
hydration and it's clinically proven to
visibly reduce wrinkles in one week how
much is this product it's available at
Walmart for under $25 ok let's go
[Music]